because like all of my worst fear is
manifested today I was having my best
friend's hair I am very excited actually
um I always love a new haircut and I
trust her I'm thinking like a rachel
bilson from like circa OC era you know
they're just like nice long layers a
little bit off the leg I want to give
her bangs I think she has a face for
bangs yeah she has nice cheekbones I
think that I can do this
I'm feeling really caught I hope you can
do better I'm feeling really good
please don't come okay what are you
doing giving you to mention shake why
are you talking like that you're talking
like an evil genius and it's making me
semi uncomfortable this how you usually
portray him um you know I I do both I do
middle I think I just felt like that
might be comforting like we've been
friends for so long those let's keep it
that way you have very good like bedside
hair manners because you feel you sound
confident and because you sound
confident I feel a little better
no sounds like a lot you know this looks
good
got that oh yeah so would you go out to
lunch with me like this yeah I got to
lunch with you in anyway what are you
hoping to see when you loo here I'm
hoping to not cry
yeah you think so ok good ok good only
look at oh my god you know I may not
even have to go fine look at you I know
we did it it's like a roller coaster fun
and scary hey I may be calling you up in
like three months would be a living room
girl yeah true I love her I love it and
let's go out I know let's swap them you
know we're gonna rock this out to LA
yeah